[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اتهم معارضون سوريون النظام
بالسعي لاحداث تغيير في التركيبه السكانيه
في بعض المناطق منها السويداء وذلك عبر
تهجير سكانها على اسس مذهبيه ودينيه ومنح
السوريه لمئات الالاف من اللبنانيين
والعراقيين والايرانيين واليمنيين نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في محورين هل
يحتاج النظام السوري لتغيير التركيبه
السكانيه في معاقل معارضيه في ظل التطورات
الميدانيه
الراهنه مدى تقبل الواقع الاجتماعي في
سوريا لاي تغيير في بنيته على الصعيدين
القبلي
والديني
[موسيقى]
مخطط تغيير البنيه السكانيه في سوريا بدا
قبل عامين وفق المعارضه السوريه التي تشير
الى ان النظام منح الجنسيه السوريه لنحو
750 الف شخص من لبنان والعراق واليمن
وايران وتعتبر مصادر مختلفه ان حرق السجل
العقاري في حمص يعد احد دلائل هذا المخطط
الرامي الى السيطره على حمص وحماه ومحافظه
دمشق ووصلها بمعاقل النظام على الساحل
السوري يقع هذا فيما قالت الامم المتحده
ان تدفق اللاجئين السوريين وصل الى معدل
لم يحدث منذ الاباده الجماعيه في رواندا
قبل 20
عاما الحولي كشفت تطورات الازمه السوريه
وعمليات النظام العسكري عن صعد جديده في
محافظه حمص اتهامات من قبل لمعارض النظام
تتلخص في ان نظام الرئيس بشار الاسد يحاول
هنا كسب جوله اخرى في حربه مع المعارضه
وذلك بتغيير خارطه المنطقه السكانيه وفي
محافظه الرقه الائتلاف الوطني السوري
المعارض تحدث عن استهداف قوات النظام
لمؤسسات مفصليه في المحافظه بشكل متعمد
مشيرا لحرق مبنى السجل العقاري ووصف ذلك
بانه يندرج ضمن محاولات النظام لتغيير
الطبيعه السكانيه وكان جملات رئيس الحزب
التقدم الاشتراكي اللبناني قد اشار في وقت
سابق لذات الموضوع قائلا انه يتيح استبدال
الملكيات بملكي اناس ينتمون لمذاهب معينه
ضمن مخطط النظام المنطلق من استراتيجيه
تحويل الاكثريه الى اقليه كما اصدر ناشطون
سوريون من السويداء بيانا رفضوا فيه مشروع
منح الجنسيه السوريه ل 4 الف من
اللبنانيين والعراقيين ذكر البيان ان
غالبيتهم عناصر من حزب الله وفي المقابل
اعتبر رئيس حزب التوحيد العربي اللبناني
وهو حزب مصنف ضمن قوى الثامن من اذار
الداعمه للنظام السوري ان التغيير
الديموغرافي في سوريا مستحيل بحكم الواقع
ونفى ارساله مقاتلين لبنانيين لسوريا بغرض
منحهم الجنسيه وتوطينهم بالسويداء لا
اعتقد بان هناك تغيير ديموغرافي لا بحمص
ولا بالسويداء اولا شيء هي بتكلف حروب
كبيره كثير وما بتخلص ثاني شيء يعني اليوم
تركيه الدوله السوريه يعني ب 90% من منا
بعدها من الاخوان السنه يعني هلق في فرق
بين ما يكون واحد عنده تمنيات وفرق
بالواقع لكن ذلك لا ينفي اللغط الدائر حول
الموضوع بشده حتى قبل اشتراك حزب الله في
القتال مع القوات السوريه في القصير
واجزاء اخرى في حمص ونبهت المعارضه لما
وصفته بسعي النظام مع حزب الله وايران
لتامين مواقع بعينها بتغيير تركيبتها
السكانيه لثرائه بالثروات الطبيعيه
واطلالتها الاستراتيجيه على البحر
المتوسط لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من جده زياد ابو حمدان عضو الائتلاف
الوطني السوري من بيروت الدكتور وسام
احماده الكاتب والمحلل السياسي المقرب من
قوى الثامن من اذار اهلا بكما استاد ابو
حمدان ما الدليل على هذا المخطط ب تهجير
سكان وجلب سكان
اخرين مساء الخير سيدتي لك وللسيدات
والساده
المشاهدين في الحقيقه
نحن ننظر الى اي اي تصرف او سلوك من من
هذا النظام نظره الريبه والشك منذ البدايه
اي وان التهجير الحاد الحاصل لسكان الجنوب
وخاصه في درعا وفي
محيط
المدينه الى ولا احد يملك متى يعود هؤلاء
المه مهجرون
واللاجئون وهناك معسكرات للتدريب يقوم
عليها
النظام
ودائما على تركيز القوه في في الجنوب
ونحن لدينا معطيات كثيره على الارض ان
هناك توزيع اسلحه
وهناك
حركات مغطاه بالتشيع والنشر الفكر الشيعي
تسري في في الجنوب وفي كل مكان في سوريا
وهنا هنا كثير من الحسينيات التي انتشرت
عبر الاراضي السوريه في السنوات السابقه
فهذا امر نحن ننظر اليه نظره شك وريبه
ونرغب التثبت منه تثبت وثائقيا حتى يمكن
الفصل في في ذلك لكن علينا ان ننبه من
واجبنا الوطني تجاه هذه القضيه الحساسه
حيث ان اهل السويداء او الدروز عموما
القاطنين في جبل العرب او كما
يسميه ساكنوه ويحبوا ان ي يسموه لان سقفه
عروبي بالدرجه الاولى
اي كانوا دائما على طرفي نقيض مع اي حكومه
غير وطنيه في دمشق من ايام الحكم التركي
حتى ايام الفرنسيين وايام الحكومات
المتقلبه على سوريا لذلك وجب ان ننبه لهذا
الموضوع بكل بكل جديه و وايضا هناك دلائل
وقرائن على شراء اراضي حول السويداء في
الشمال
والجنوب دكتور وسام حما دكتور وسام حماده
السيد اام وهاب في لبنان نفى ان يكون حصل
هذا الامر الوقع الاجتماعي لا يتقبل هكذا
تغيير كما قال ولكن لما مثلا حرق السجل
العقاري في حمس برايك يعني بدايه بعد
توجيه التحيه لك
[موسيقى]
ولمشاهدة موي اي يكاد ياكل الاخضر واليابس
يوميا على الاراضي السوريه من اقصى الشمال
الى اقصى الجنوب ومن اقصى الشرق الى اقصى
الغرب اي ان يحرق مركز من هذه المراكز
هناك عشرات المراكز الثقافيه والو والطبيه
والسياسيه ومنها اكيد ما يتعلق في المجتمع
المدني السوري احرق في عدد كبير من
المحافظات وال والدوائر التي كانت تحت
مرمى النيران من كلا الطرفين كي لا يعني
كي اكون متواضعا
اي السؤال هو هل فعلا سوريا والنظام
السوري يعني يحتاج الى هكذا يعني فعل او
رد فعل في
عمليه تجنيس ايه دوله كبرى مثل سوريا تملك
ملايين من ال من ال من ال المواطنين
السوريين الذين يعني يتميزوا عن باقي
الدول العربيه بهذا الكم و من ال من الحس
الوطني والحس العروبي وخاصه فيما يتعلق في
في يعني في جبل العرب و والاخوه الدروز
الذين يتمتعون بحساسيه جدا كبيره على
المستوى الفقهي والمستوى الثقافي في اي
تغيير يعني او محاوله تغيير ديموغرافي و
ولا اعتقد ان يعني هكذا
مشروع يبصر النور في سوريا حتى وان كان
هناك راغبون وانا اشك ان هناك راغبون في
هذا في هذا الامر سوريا لا تحتاج يعني انا
اعتقد ان هناك عدد كبير من الدول يعني
العربيه الصغيره التي تحاول بين الفينه
والاخرى ان تجنس م من مختلف اقاع الدنيا
لكي تخلق توازن ديموغرافي و وتخلق توازن
طائفي في سوريا لا يمكن ان يخلق هذا
التوازن لان اولا سوريا يعني السواد
الاعظم من الطائفه السنيه الكريمه اي ال
ال الاقليات في سوريا تاريخيا هم هم محفوظ
لدى هذه لدى هذه المجموعه الكبيره من من
السنه اما فيما يتعلق بما تفضل به ضيفك
الكريم الاستاذ زياد انه هناك تخوف من
تشيع وهناك تخوف من اقامه حسينيه هنا او
هناك انا اعيده الى التاريخ السوري العريق
في في في المنشات والجوامع والمساجد التي
يعني تصدح ليلا نهارا ب ب بعبر قارئين ال
ومشايخ السنه والمفتين الس سنه في على
كامل الاراضي السوريه كما تصدح بالكنائس
بج يعني باجراس ولا اعتقد هناك عاقل يعني
ممكن ان ان ان يصدق ان ان سوريا او اي بلد
عربي ممكن ان يتشيع عبر 100 او 200 او او
300 شخص اذا وجدوا على على كل يعني رغم
اني انا من الاشخاص الذين تقارير دكتور
تقارير تشير الى ان النظام منح الجنسيه
السوريه لنحو 700 و الف شخص من لبنان
والعراق واليمن وايران هل هنالك دخان بدون
نار خلينا خلينا خلينا نشوف هذه التقارير
من اين صدرت سيدتي يعني الكره الارضيه
الان تقوم على على على التقارير نكتشف كل
يوم يعني ان هناك تقرير يكذب التقرير الذي
سبقه نبدا من من تقرير اساسي خرب الامه
العربيه فيما يتعلق بالسلاح السلاح الدمار
الشامل في العراق واكتشفنا ان هناك ت ير
كاذبه للمخابرات
الامريكيه كل يوم نكتشف انت موافق ان
هنالك الملايين من اللاجئين الذين اخرجوا
من من سوريا هذا موافق عليه طبعا انا انا
لست موافقا انا انا انا اقر ان في لبنان
تحديدا الان يعني اخ احصائيات حوالي
المليون و200 ال بس السؤال لماذا هجروا
يعني السوري قبل سنتين ضمن الاجوبه على
لماذا هجروا انه هنالك تغيير واقع
ديموغرافي انتقل لسيد ابو حمدان اذا دكتور
يسال من اين اتت هذه التقارير ومجددا كما
سالتك في بدايه الحلقه ما الدليل ربما
يظهر تقرير اخر ين في التقرير
الاول اختي الكريمه من حق ضيفك الكريم ان
يتساءل طبعا
لكن الموضوع لا يتعلق بسنه او سنتين
الموضوع كان له
جذور منذ طويل من عشرات السنوات لكن هناك
رساله وقعت تحت
يدي كتبها احد الناشطين في هذا المجال وهو
اسمه ابو يوسف الحسيني وجهت
الى الرئيس الاسد في 7/9
2004 تشير فيه الى التغلغل الايراني
والتغلغل الشيعي في جسم الدوله السوريه
وا وايضا تمت الاشاره الى الى تدخل السفير
الايراني في الشؤون الداخليه لسوريا وهذا
يدعم حقيقه واضحه ان النشاط بدا قديما في
الجانب السياسي والجانب الاجتماعي ل
لتغيير الديموغرافيا في سوريا وتغيير
التوجهات والانتماءات الدينيه نحن كنا
نتمنى من ايران ان تصدر لنا تكنولوجيا او
تصدر لنا
لنا علوم او تصدر لنا ما يفيد الشعب
السوري على مبدا الصداقه والتبادل المصالح
المشتركه لا ان تصدر
لنا حسينيات ودعوات شيعيه و والعوده الى
الخلف هذا كل كل ما في الامر يعني الان
لكن نعود ونقول ان المهجرين الذين يعترف
الدكتور بوجودهم بالملايين في لبنان وفي
غير لبنان
اي هناك واقع
حدث على الارض
حقيقه ويجب ملء هذا الفراغ لان المواطنين
السوريين
اللاجئين وضعوا في حاله عداوه مطلقه مع
هذا النظام الذي هجرهم وقتلهم وعاقبهم
جماعيا بدون بدون ذنب للكثير منهم فهناك
معطيات على الارض نخشى تماما ان ان يتم
استغلالها والبحث في هذا الموضوع يجب ان
يكون على مستوى وطني وانا انبه الى هذه
القضيه ل وقوف ضدها بكل الاتجاهات و وكل
الناس مسؤولين عن ذلك طيب دكتور بالاضافه
الى ما ذكره من مخطط قديم ضو يقول لديه
دليل عبر رساله حصل عليها مؤرخه ب 7924
هذا المخطط القديم اصلا ليست فقط سوريا من
حكى عن هذه المحاولات الايرانيه للتشيع
داخل البلدان لكن بغض النظر عن هذا نريد
ان نتحدث عن الان انقل اليك ما قاله وليد
جنبلاط
قال هذه الخطوه من احراق للسجلات العقاريه
تسهل عمليه التواصل المذهبي والسياسي بين
الساحل ودمشق عبر استبدال ملكيات باخرى
لمنت مين لمذاهب اخرى وقد في هذا الاطار
وضعت مجازر البويضه وبانياس وسواهما من
المناطق السوريه لتامين شكل من اشكال
الانسيابيه الجغرافيه بين مناطق معينه
وخلق واقع ديمغرافي جديد ما ما رايك بهذا
التصور لوليد جنبلاط
يعني قبل قبل تصور الاستاذ وليد جنبلاط
يعني اول شيء انا اتمنى على يعني اي
الاستاذ زياد ان يعني يراعي اي يعني عقل
المست المستمعين وعقلنا يعني اذا الاخ ابو
يوسف بال 2004 قدم رساله ولا ندري من هو
ابو يوسف وهناك عشرات ابو يوسف الذين يعني
ممكن ان نطلق شهود عيان واثبتت التجربه ان
هذا يعني جزء مضر بالثوره اذا سميت ثوره
على كل اما اما التكهنات و ونعتمد يعني
لغه التكهنات و ونعتقد لا اعتقد انه هذا
الامر يؤدي بنتائج ايجابيه لاي حراك كان
على اي مستوى اما فيما يتعلق بتصريح
الاستاذ وليد جنبلاط الاستاذ وليد جنبلاط
هو الحقيقه طرف يعني طرف في هذا الصراع
معلن عداءه بالكامل للنظام السوري
اي له رايه الخاص جدا فيما يتعلق ب
بالصراع في سوريا لا نستطيع ان ان ان ناخ
خذه يعني ك ك كمسوغ قانوني هو يطلق احيانا
يعني تصريحات وتكهنات يتراجع عنها خلال
التصريح الذي يلي اي حتى هذه اللحظه كل ما
قيل في هذا الموضوع لم يجد اي يعني اي
تاثير على المستوى الشارع وهذا هو الذي
يعني يهم ال ال اين تاثير ما يحاك حول
سوريا في موضوع التجنيس والمجني وهناك منذ
عشرات السنين كل دول العالم كل دول العالم
قاطبه سيدتي تقدم جنسيات احيانا ل لطالبين
او لمقيمين اوروبا وامريكا تجنس يوميا
عشرات اذا اذا مش مئات والاف لم نشعر هذا
يعني هذا الاحساس بالتغيير الديموغرافي
على على المستوى السوري ونحن الزائرون الى
سوريا منذ نعومه اظافرنا نحن والخليجيون و
وكل العالم الذي كان يشبه سوريا انها
الدوله تكاد تكون النموذجيه في العيش
المشترك فيما بين مكونات واثني و والمذاهب
والطوائف التي توجد بها بالعشرات اذا
استطعنا ان ان ان ان نعدد هذا هذا هذا امر
انا اعتقد يعني ليس مفيدا ابدا ان يعني ان
نثير زوبعه لا نستطيع ان نقدم فيها اي
دليل و والزمن يثبت دائما عكس هذه
الطروحات لل الم الشاهد العربي اصبح الان
يعني في حاجه في حاجه الى احترام عقله عبر
عبر يعني عبر التصريحات وان كانت من
مسؤولين مخضرمين في عالم السياسه اليوم
السياسي في العالم العربي مع الاسف لم يعد
يملك مصداقيه لانه كل يوم ياتينا بخبر
ونقيض ساعود اليكما ضيفي الكرام ولكن بعد
هذا هذا الفاصل القصير فابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش الاتهامات الموجهه للنظام السوري
بالسعي لتغيير التركيبه السكانيه في مناطق
مختلفه من
البلاد سيد ابو حمدان هل قبل ان نخوض اكثر
في التفاصيل هل لديك رد على ما قاله قبل
الاعلان قبل الفاصل الدكتور
وسام
اي ضيفك الكريم في بيروت اي اي ا يعني
لابد ان اشكرها بدايه على على ثقته
بالدروز وبال المواطنين السوريين الذين لا
يقبلون
اي بالتاكيد حركات التوطين او او حركات
التجنيس مهما كان
مصدرها
وايضا اشكره على اقراره بان هناك ملايين
المجرين واللاجئين
السوريين يعيشون الان خارج سوريا و ولا
ولا ادرك تماما اذا كان هو لديه جواب متى
يمكن ان يعود هؤلاء اللاجئون وهل هناك خطه
لدى النظام السوري لاعاده هؤلاء اللاجئين
الى ارض اراضي الوطن بسرعه قبل ان نتعرض
او نواجه مشكله فلسطينيه جديده في
سوريا اتمنى ان نجاوب على هذه الاسئله
الكبرى
اي التي هي استحقاقات بدات اي اي امامنا
واضحه واضحه وعلينا الت ط ربما هذا السؤال
هذا السؤال ليس مسؤول عنه الدكتور وسام
اريد منك شرحا مفصلا اكثر لانه قال علينا
ان نحترم عقول المشاهد التقارير وتصريحات
السياسيين عليها ان تحترم عقل المشاهد هل
لك ان تشرح للمشاهد الان كيف يمكن عمليا
على الارض وانت سوري وتدري اكثر منا
الواقع السوري الديموغرافي والجغرافي هلك
ان تشرح لنا كيف يمكن تغيير الواقع
الديموغرافي في سوريا يعني وصل حمس حماه
الى مرورا بدمشق الى الساحل لانشاء هذه
الدويله انا اظن ان وصفات الدويلات او
التقسيم في سوريا هي وصفات للخراب والدمار
وليست وصفات يمكن ان تعيش او تلقى قبولا
لدى الشعب السوري ومن يخطط لها او يفكر
فيها
اي اظن انه ان تفكيره قاصر عن فهم تاريخ
وطبيعه الشعب السوري ولكن كيف يجري تحضير
لحث الان من من تهجير نعم يجري التحضير
لها عندما تهجر مدن باكملها او قرى
باكملها في محيط محيط محافظه حمص وفي
تلكلخ وفي والقصير وفي اماكن كثيره اي تم
تهجير اهالي وسكان تلك المناطق وايضا تم
تهجير سكان في في قرى درعا مثل الحراك
وكثير من القرى الاخرى اي واصبحت هذه
القرى فارغه من من سكانها تماما
اي بالتاكيد ه هذه مؤشرات خطيره ان هذه
هذا المكان او هذه الجغرافيا سيملا بعناصر
اخرى واستقدام
ايضا جيوش او او ميليشيات
او او قوى داعمه للنظام من خارج سوريا
اي تدين للنظام بال بالولاء وتنفذ مخططه
ندرك تماما ان هذ هذه هذه الجيوش او هذه
الميليشيات لابد ان تقطف ثمره هذا التدخل
و وتكافئ على ذلك بتوطين في اماكن تواجدها
او اماكن تحقيق انتصاراتها فنحن من هذا
الباب نشك نعم نشك ولدينا كل كل الحق في
ذلك دكتور وسام اذا شرح لنا ايضا هناك
شراء الاراضي نعم شراء الاراضي شراء
الاراضي والرقم هو مليارات دولار دفعتهم
ايران لشراء هذه الاراضي باضافه الى كل ما
ذكره السيد ابو حمدان افراغ ايضا ريف دمشق
تلكلخ لحراك درعا كل ذلك اليس من حق الناس
ان تتساءل من سيسكن هذه المناطق المفرغه
من النظام لن يسكن هذه المناطق الا ا
اهلها وسكانها وهناك عشرات الدلائل على
ذلك حين تحرر اي منطقه في سوريا و و ويعلن
الجيش العربي السوري ان هذه المنطقه اصبحت
امنه نجد ان خلال 24 ساعه بدا بدات الناس
في العوده انا اعطيك هل عاد احد من لبنان
دكتور عفوا هل عاد احد من لبنان انت تعيش
في لبنان والارقام الى تزايد في لبنان وفي
الاردن الى التزايد و 5000 يموتون شهريا
بحسب الامم المتحده وتقول هناك من يعود
يعني اسمحي لي اسمحي لي اولا يعني الارقام
التي تصدر عن المنظمات
الدوليه والمنظمات العالميه لا لا لا يبنى
عليها اي شيء ولا تحترم اي اي يعني اي عقل
في في البشر وم نصدق اذا دكتور يعني ف
فرغه الدنيا كلها من نصدق دكتور يعني انت
تقول علينا احترام عقل المشاهد الامم
المتحده الان لم تعد موثوقه بالنسبه اليك
من نصدق ا نصدق الواقع افراغ المناطق وادق
الواقع انا اقول لك ا اولا اولا سوريا
اولا سوريا تعداد سكانها بالملايين يعني
ليس والمساحه شاسعه في سوريا وطبيعه
الصراع
وتنقل الصراع الدموي من من نقطه الى اخرى
يؤدي دائما الى تهج جير هذه الناس نحن نحن
نذكر في 2006 سيدتي الكريمه في لبنان هجر
الجنوب كاملا وخلال 33 يوم لم يبقى في
الجنوب الا المقاتلين و والعائلات الداعمه
للمقاتلين وحين اعلن وقف اطلاق النار انا
من الناس الذين كنت مشرف على احد المواقع
ال اللوجستيه التي تقوم بالخدمات للمهجرين
الساعه 8 الصبح اتينا لنقدم لهم الخبز وما
شاكل وجدنا ان السيارات كلها محمله وعائده
الى الجنوب الناس تعود الى اوطانها الناس
تعود الى بيوتها المدمره الناس تعود الى
اراضيها وخي ه الفلسطينيون يعني لا ادري
هنا وجه المقارنه الان انت قلت لي عادوا
من عاد من لبنان اعطيني مثلا المق اعطيك
مثلا هناك عدد كبير من السوريين الذين
ويعني وانا ا علم بعشرات بل بالمئات الذين
مناطقهم اعتبرت امنه وعادوا وهناك مئات
غيرهم ايضا دخلوا الاراضي اللبنانيه لان
اراضيهم يعني ابتدات بها المعارك العسكريه
انا لا اقول ان ليس هناك مهجرين انا اقول
اسباب التهجير الحقيقه لا علاقه لها ابدا
في عمليه التغيير الديموغرافي دعونا نضع
يعني الا لما انت واثق الى هذه الدرجه
والحسم بالموضوع دكتور بشكل سريع لاني
اريد ان اختم مع ضيفي من جده لما يعني انت
تقول اولا تقارير لا نصدق لماذا نصدق الان
ما
تقوله انا لا انا لا يعني لا اطلب من من
حضرتك ولا من المشاهد ان ان يصدق او انا
لست
م هناك هناك راي عام يؤيد هذه الفكره
وهناك راي عام يعني كما تفضل استاذ زياد
لا يؤيدها انما على ارض الواقع يستطيع اي
اي لجنه اي لجنه
تختارونها تكون محايده نجد انا انا لا
اقول انه ليس هناك مشكله اقول ان الناس
سوف تعود ولا خوف على
سوريا اي تغير الناس سوف تعود ما رايك ب
30 ثانيه لو
سمحت ا الدكتور وسام يتكلم بامانه ايضا لا
اعتقد انه لديه اي حقائق او وثائق لعوده
السوريين المهجرين وليس هناك اي بادره
حقيقيه من قبل الدوله السوريه او قبل
الحكومه السوريه لاثبات ذلك اما فيما يخص
فيما يخص انتقاده للسيد وليد جنبلاط اي
بتغيير مواقفه وتعديلها اظن ان السيد وليد
جنبلاط يقوم ب
بتلك التوازنات
الخطيره والحساسه من منطق وطني ويقف على
على صمام امان في في لبنان وان وقوفه
ال كونه زعيم طائفه درزيه في لبنان على
معرفه سويده شكرا جزيلا لك سيد زياد ابو
حمدان عضو الاتلاف الوطني السوري كنت معنا
من جده وايضا اشكر من بيروت دكتور وسام
حمادي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي المقرب اذار
شكرا جزيلا الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا